Trump criticized for calling Hezbollah
very smart as he talked of potential
risk to Israel the former president also
called Israel's defense minister a jerk
what I absolutely love about the story
is ABC News doesn't actually give you
the full picture Trump did not just say
Hezbollah was very smart Trump said they
attack me for saying things like this
when I point out that you know Hezbollah
they're smart they know what they're
doing they're going to attack from the
North and then an Israeli defense
minister said I hope they don't attack
us from the north because weak there so
then Hezbollah does because they're
smart right they're attacking Trump over
this now trying to make it seem like
he's anti-israel or something like that
intelligence doesn't make you good or
evil you can be evil and intelligent you
can be good and intelligent he said xiin
Ping's intelligent he was right the
guy's not dumb he's smart not
necessarily good that's not a claim of
good or evil so yes people can be very
smart it does not qualify their their
morals there was some celebrity that got
canceled like a couple years ago or
maybe it's longer than a couple years
ago for saying that Hitler was smart he
was right that's not even arguable I
would consider him evil but he was
definitely had high intelligence
absolutely evil right I mean to even
reach the position of power I mean you
got to give Trump intelligence points
just for reaching the point of
presidency alone and then you know be a
billionaire but look at this Michael
Tracy Nails it he says it's hilarious
when Republicans try to attack one
another for not standing with Israel
hard enough they all have the exact same
position so so uh so must desperately
latch onto trivial turns of phrase like
it means anything yeah I'm sure Trump is
a huge fan of Hezbollah it's also I want
to play the clip DeSantis waram says new
Trump Praises Hezbollah calling the Iran
back terror group very smart hours after
they attacked Israel but actually listen
to this and then two nights ago I read
all of Biden security people can you
imagine National Defense people and they
said gee I hope Hezbollah doesn't attack
from the north because that's the most
vulnerable spot I said wait a minute you
know hbel is very smart they're all very
smart the Press doesn't like when they
say you know I said that President Chief
of China 1.4 billion people he controls
it with an iron fist I said he's a very
smart man they killed me the next day I
said he was smart what am I going to say
he knows what H they're very smart and
they have a National Defense Minister or
somebody saying I hope hezb doesn't
attack us from the north so the
following morning they attacked yeah
they might not have been doing it but if
you listen to this jerk you would attack
from the north because he said that's
our weak spot this is why Trump went
this is it this is why the people who
listen to Trump end up supporting him
like Brandon Str story where he was like
I'm going to debunk this narrative
listen to Trump actually talk and went
oh like had this transformation Trump is
roasting the media for insulting him for
saying that Hezbollah and xinping are
smart it's crazy to me that's plainly
true yeah no they're really dumb what
identifying your enemy strengths is the
one of the first steps in defeating your
enemy yeah mhm the simpler explanation
here is it's also just it's just verif
fying people and they're not sending
their best all over again right the
media is just taking advantage of the
fact that a lot of the people who are
watching it are going to read the
headline and they're not going to
actually listen to the clip through the
whole way and that's he does fall into
that trap he's been known to fall in
that trap but the people that are going
to look at this and take that as an own
already are looking to hate him well I'm
wonder I'm wondering I don't know much
about the Hezbollah attack in the north
is this the Israelis set them up did
they create an area of the north that
they that they said was weak in order to
draw Hezbollah in and so that they could
get them where they want them and maybe
heah is not as smart as he thinks they
are I know nothing about it I'm
wondering cuz why would the Israeli
defense minister announce their weakness
out loud well I mean we saw that even in
in the war on terror we saw people like
on like openly saying like this is the
next troop movement and stuff like that
and people were who were obviously
watching CNN in Afghanistan were like oh
okay well now we know where to go now we
know where to defend Etc it's just like
it's just like a huge it's a huge uh
operational uh misguiding or not what's
the word I'm trying to think of the word
here hubis uh maybe not huis but just
like it's like why would you do that
it's just like an it's a mistake you
know to say that like to literally tell
people you're weak they're probably
going to watch your news media and
figure it out someone's going to be
watching and that's like that's the
mistake they made I don't know it's I
don't know if they actually goed them
into it though like you're saying I know
very little about the Hezbollah moves in
the north but if they've got Hezbollah
out of position right now you know that
might not be a bad thing for them I mean
I will say I don't know much about that
situation either however watching that
first of all makes me appreciate how
funny just the way he talks is and I
always know he's gaining more power and
sort of like on his way back up when he
starts getting more unhinged in his
speech because he's really funny and
that you just see can see it but also
during in the time we're in right now
with everything going on that peace time
that we took for granted maybe not us
but a lot of people took for granted
during his presidency it's it's looking
a lot sweeter to have again hopefully
you know it makes me more Pro Trump than
they ever but you know it it's gotten so
bad under Joe Biden that people are
begging for Trump trump back is kind of
funny yeah yeah first time I ever in my
life have considered voting for Donald
Trump was today really is because I
don't see another War Commander that we
have running for president right now
right true Joe Joe Rogan said something
similar if it's Biden or Trump he would
vote for Trump over Biden I would take
Viv I just feel like where what's his
presence I don't know is he actually
challenging Donald Trump I I but I mean
I I trust VI face to face I like where
his head's at where his spirits at but
Don's got the experience of working in
the white house for four years and I
feel it's we a very desperate situation
not just that Donald Trump negotiated
internationally for decades yeah and we
what he was doing goes back to my belief
that we need the Russians as allies if
we're going to hold the line and he has
that you know going back to what I kind
of said that like slight unhinged thing
that's actually a very positive thing
like we were kind of saying before we
went on air it's like why wouldn't you
want the world to be ever so slightly
afraid of messing with our guy I mean
that's just common sense when Trump said
there there's that phone call that got
released or whatever where Trump is like
you know I told Vladimir Putin and shiin
ping that if they invaded I would nuke
them and uh he maybe he didn't believe
me but maybe 5% it's good enough yeah
something like that it was but that's
real like that's actually kind of how
the world works you in ukine will nuke
you it's like uh for real speak softly
and carry a big stick is Teddy Roosevelt
but the big stick isn't just the nuclear
armaments that we have it's the ability
to utilize them that's the big Biden
doesn't seem to have that people aren't
afraid of that guy no no and that 5%
margin that you just said it's like
that's enough that's enough to not want
to do it she like calls Vladimir and
he's like I just got off the phone with
Trump and Vladimir is like yeah me too
and he's like did he say he was going to
Nuke you he did do you believe him I
don't know man let's chill out better to
not risk it yeah he's going to Nuke you
that's crazy that's funny did he get on
the phone a lot with Putin well I don't
I don't I don't know to what extent like
it actually was conveyed I am quite
worried at the idea of of a of a US
president threatening to Nuke another
Nation but the general idea is peace
through strength right there's there was
no conflict there were no new Wars in
fact wars were winding down and Trump
was trying to get our troops out of the
Middle East and working on peace
agreements the proof is in the pudding
no matter how people want to portray his
efficacy it's like we did just have one
state of being which was there wasn't
anything like this going down it would
also interesting just like for people
who might be more open to it now who
just either didn't care didn't pay
attention but to look into like the the
negotiations between like him and other
countries or the Abraham Accords to look
at what happened or maybe now they look
at him going into North Korea with a new
you know in a new light because they're
seeing just how volatile overseas
relations actually are uh that might
actually play in his favor I'm concerned
if uh a global war goes hot which I mean
it's already heating up but uh that
remember World War I the Bolshevik
Revolution immediately after the war
shortly after the War Began Communist
Revolution in Russia so that that would
happen in the United States that the pro
Palestine all these marches and stuff
that there would be an armed Uprising in
the United States to take control of the
country to lead it to protect Palestine
over Israel and then I could see us
having the internal struggle not even
being able to help Israel because we're
dealing with our own crap so I think if
we can get ahead of it prepare for it
now and prevent it it's the other way
around the the the far left is being run
the coals for for supporting Terror I'm
glad that's it's the difference is they
didn't have the internet in 2014 or 1914
so they didn't see it coming but we see
it coming we see this crazy manipulative
Underdog always first strategy and it's
not working and the government doesn't
like it either that's the benefit of it
is the the always first yeah it's like
Underdog always make the underdog win oh
right right right right Marxism you're
right and then lie about who the
underdog really is right yeah yeah yep
it's them when they're when they're
losing a need to win mhm it's their
friends when their friends are losing
and need to win if they're winning
they're still The Underdogs they're
still losing and there's always more
work to be done there
is yeah but I see what you mean by that
but the thing about 1917 is that they
literally left the war they left the
world war because they were fighting the
war since the beginning I think and then
they had a civil war from that um but
yeah I see I can see where that you're
where you're drawing these like the
analogy towards but uh I don't know also
with what's going on here right is like
a lot of this this is college kids that
are laring as revolutionaries and it's
not really the same thing I really do
believe in a lot of respects that it uh
things don't get bad as like things
don't get worse until food starts
rationing and people can't feed their
families and then you have a lot more to
worry about the French thing is
interesting did you see the French the
revolts in France they were prot
Republic yeah and they were protesting
Pro Palestine and and then the
government said that's illegal and then
they started protesting that the
government made their protest illegal
and then things are getting hot Lally no
reverse that happened within like
days tomorrow is the global Jihad day
and there's all these protests all over
the world in support of Hamas it's it's
crazy what advice is just you know if
you're armed you know stay safe stay
armed stay in your house go out don't I
don't live in a city we were out in the
middle of nowhere so I'm good like some
people are like just go about your
business don't let Terror stop you other
everyone look everyone uh here is fine
except for Blair Blair's on a plane
tomorrow right love the day y'all books
me but um but real question half kidding
mostly serious am I crazy for kind of
wanting to drive home no no stay another
day yeah hang out yeah we'll just move I
feel like I'll think about it I put
flight off tomorrow as well CU I don't
want to feel like I'm being honic about
something but it's also like I mean it's
the Friday the 13th it's just crazy
we'll just we we'd love to have you
we'll extend your flight and then
tomorrow we play poker I'll think about
it I'll think about it don't don't
travel on Friday the 13th Jihad yeah and
the solar eclipse and that red heer
thing like what happens and they're like
look you had all the warnings in the
world like it's something about the red
heer that particularly is like I don't
know regarding the red heer that's like
the the move for the the like the
extremist religious sect of is the
Israeli government that they want to
prop bring about the Third Temple and
instantiate the the second coming I I'm
concerned that if they if they try and
force it through the first coming right
like the Messiah will finally come for
real but but Christians uh have like
Christians and Jews believe the same
thing about the red heer don't they it's
just that for for Christians the second
coming and for Juds it's the first
coming yes I don't know I'm not a
religious scholar I was just reading
reading some articles about it yeah but
isn't like if the Messiah comes isn't
that he doesn't just stay and chill and
like live with us right that's the end
of the world right the Messiah leads an
army and take conquers the world and
then brings World Peace but is that
Christian or is that Jewish I don't know
they don't say So within Judaism the
Messiah has not come yet to be the first
coming and I don't think in that in that
worldview that it's the end of the world
within christiandom if the if the second
coming occurs then yes it does mean the
end of the world in Catholicism
particularly it's different in different
sects of Christianity too so I guess
we'll see who's right but what is it in
Mormonism because this would be the
third coming yeah uh I really yeah be
the second or third yeah third coming I
guess you're right because in uh I I I
could be wrong but Mormons believe that
Jesus came like a thousand years later
to the North America or something like
that I don't know if years later yeah I
don't know if it was a thousand years
later when he was currently on Earth
that he traveled across ocean I don't
know my concern is that when realism
kicks in if you try and force this thing
through military and execution that it's
going to it's going to backfire like the
Israelis think that they're going to do
some good by doing this I have a fear
that it's going to backfire on them so I
that's the real side of it I just I
don't think it's can be forced with
military I don't know I I hate to see
because it was in a book that we're
going to just kill all these people and
and force in front of the world with
video with internet video like you think
you can accomplish accom War atrocities
with internet video it's not the right
time for that cuz if you really believe
it's a prophecy and supposed to happen
it's going to happen whether you push it
or not right so just chill please
everyone chill yeah she's like I got a
plane to catch tomorrow would you CH
honestly I have a life to live like 20
songs I haven't recorded yet I'm like
every time I go to play video games now
I'm like I am wasting valuable time it's
which is good what's that and you're
running out I know that's what it feels
like like I just spent the last two
years playing video games at night not
worrying like uh I can't wait for
tomorrow what the hell is tomorrow this
is now this is it this is time time is
not real it is always right now and it's
like no time to wa I mean there's this
create what you want to create right now
now is the time yeah and there's been
several incidents in the past few years
that we should have just learned that
and kept knowing that right but it comes
into more clarity during times like this
where it's like half joking but half
serious on a plane and I'm kind of
scared about it you know it's like it
comes into clear of view that reality I
had a I was in a band called the Panic
for a long time and I didn't really want
to be in the band but it was falling
apart I was getting high beforehand I
wasn't practicing properly and
eventually they're like all right Ian
you're out of the band I was like No And
then I like gave it everything and
they're like it's too late and I was out
of the band was the band called Blind
Melon it was called the Panic yes it was
BL Blind Melon actually I was the
original the Panic watch the music video
for Blind Melon with no rain great song
it's just like four Ian but the lesson I
learned is no for real that'd be a good
band name I'm not kidding the lesson I
learned is don't wait till the last
minute to give it everything give it
everything right now go hard now yeah
true
bro I swear like this video it's just
like Ian modeled his whole life off of
these guys this changed my life in 19
not the little girl in the bumble
Bumblebee costume where's the guy at
look at this guy oh yeah bro that's like
that's him look at him it's literally
just like Ian wanted to be him oh man
look at
those very Ian coded good song
though we're we're trying to bring a
little levity to your lives before the
day of jihad you know a little hippie
Justice I mean I can be honest I feel
like nothing's going to happen that's
the point it's Terror they want you to
be afraid exactly exactly they want
people to like lay low not work disrupt
the economy yep disrupt the economy but
what do you do man because there's crazy
people who are like even if even if you
think that was their intention some
crazy person is going to do something it
takes one crazy person I saw Jack pic
tweeted out a video of like a car doing
donuts in the middle of the freeway in
New York did you see that I don't know
if it was Rel if it was related I don't
know if they were screaming Palestine or
something but they were it was it
blocked traffic in New York that was
today I think part of it is like it
feels like lately the world is crazy
every day so for there to be a specific
day where it's supposed to get more
crazy more crazy it's like okay it's
also the internet though it's just the
access to all of the all of the crazy
things that happen at your are now at
your fingertips and in your pocket all
the time back in the day you would have
had to watch like you know maybe they
include a couple stories like that at
the end of the news if you watch the
news when you were younger not everyone
did now you're not getting in the form
of like some stuffy dude in a in a suit
telling it to you it's in your pocket
and you're scrolling through it and
you're algorithmically being programmed
to see how how crazy the world is every
single day and that's hard on anyone's
brain and that violence you know it's
like I was thinking about like the day
everything kind of started I was flying
home from Vegas and I saw the imagery of
like people just murdered in the streets
there was like a I think it was the
image of you know the elderly people
outside the bus stop just and I cried in
the car and I was actually shocked that
I cried and then I was shocked that I
was shocked about it because I'm like
how is it shocking that I'm crying when
I'm seeing this am I that desensitized
that it's rare for me to cry when I see
a scene like that and that's society as
a whole you know it's like we are way
too desensitized to seeing just things
that you are not meant to see and in the
past you would have had to go to like
Psychotherapy to cope with the fact that
you saw it like hyper hyper
normalization yeah I've kind of been
keeping off the uh looking at the videos
I'm wondering today should I expose
myself to some of these traumatic deaths
in in I do you you you have been
watching it oh I look at all the videos
I watch I saw one of a dog getting shot
did you see that that was tough I I
don't care to see that I mean my God I
watch it all uh my view is I I not it's
not not for everybody but do you know
what the real world is or do you just
live in the safety bubble of the United
States I feel like I can't communicate
properly with the people that have been
exposed to it unless I expose myself to
it yeah and I I my view has always been
since I was uh uh like I I remember
there was a viral video of three dudes
murdering a guy in in Europe that was on
like live leak and oh yeah that one and
I was like I'm GNA watch it because this
is what this is this this evil exists
and I I I feel there's a lot of people
like I don't want to watch it I don't
want to watch it and that to me kind of
felt like please please let me stay
under the covers the monsters are
outside whereas I'm like you're better
off like this this is imagine this
little kids hide under the C covers
because they're scared of a monster or
something right like that's the worst
thing you can do because now you can't
see the threat and if there is a monster
it's coming for you thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a member
over at timcast.net